in this project we'll take a look at
creating a basic character controller
using a finite state machine
so that you can instantiate characters
in the little 3d world and move them
around
we'll be using javascript and 3js like
always and we'll be diving a bit deeper
into the animation system here
looking at some of the classes like
animation mixer
animation action and animation clip
3js has great support for animations
whether you're looking to do some simple
animations
or something much more advanced like the
soldier here 3js has you covered
you can see here there's a whole bunch
of ways you can blend multiple
animations at once
like look i can create a sort of
shuffling walk by mixing idle and walk
anyway what we want to do is take these
capabilities that 3js exposes
and wrap it all nice and neat into a
character controller that you can
conceivably
just drop in and use in your own
projects so let's get started
before we begin make sure you subscribe
to this channel and on twitter so that
you're notified when new videos are
released and you can also get previews
of what's coming up
first thing we'll start a new project so
drop down to the terminal and create one
i'll call it 3js underscore tutorial
underscore character controller
and once we have that we can add a few
simple files like the index.html and
main.js files
in a previous tutorial we covered
loading animated characters
so if you haven't watched that i covered
a lot of the basics of loading animated
characters there so definitely watch it
before you watch this one
so we'll use the code from there as a
starting point just a bit of copy paste
to get things started
we'll also need a bunch of animations so
head on over to mixmo where we can help
ourselves to a few free
really nicely done models and animations
specifically in our little example we'll
be making our characters stand around
walk run and do a little dance depending
on which keys we press
there's a really nice selection of stuff
here i grab this dance cycle
along with a nice walk and run cycle
should be fine for what we're doing
notice that i download the animation
separately by downloading this without
the skin
so when we hit download we can just
select no skin and that just gets us the
animation data without needing to load
the rest
now that we've got our animation data
let's start by creating a few basic
classes
we're going to make a basic character
controller class which is going to
represent a single animated character
in our little world we'll also make
another class
basic character controller input which
will be responsible for listening for
keyboard input and recording keys like
up and down
that kind of thing lastly we'll make a
finite state machine and state class
we'll fill their implementations out in
a second
now you could easily put them all into
one big class but the reason we're not
going with this one
uber class is simple by decoupling these
classes you can in theory drop in
replacements like say if you have the
basic character controller and you want
to make an ai
you can simply drop in an ai input in
place of the keyboard input and voila
you have an ai character it's just neat
and tidy and saves you time in the long
run
so now the basic flow is like this the
basic character controller has an
instance of an input which will
instantiate right here in the
constructor
and it has a finite state machine the
character controller will load the fbx
files associated with
model and animations and then create a
proxy class that will let the finite
state machine
communicate with the controller to
change animations that kind of thing
you could of course just give it direct
access to the basic character controller
but i'll make a proxy class to avoid
cluttering things up
the loading is all pretty simple we load
the main model file which is what these
lines of code do
then we load each of the animations and
we store the animation clip and
animation
action from all of these in a dictionary
called this dot underscore animations
the keyboard input class is pretty
simple all this does is set a few
document listeners up for the key up and
key down events and record the relevant
ones
there's really not much in here beyond
that no special processing of anything
we're mostly just interested in walking
running so we'll record awsd for walking
the space key for doing a special
animation and the shift key for
transitioning from walking to running
the input here will get directly passed
to the finite state machine to be
interpreted
so not much to see here the real guts of
the logic is here
in the finite state machine so quick
aside
finite state machines are a really
simple way of modeling the possible
states and transitions for a character
imagine we've got this character and
we'll model some simple state for it
initially he's in the idle state since
that's kind of like the default
nothing's happening here if you were to
press forward or backward he'd be
walking
so we add this walk state and you
transition to that from the idle state
when the input was forward or backwards
similarly when you're walking and you
stop pressing those keys we transition
back
into the idle state our character isn't
going to have a ton of states
since this is just a tutorial but here's
the final finite state machine where we
have idle
walk run and dance states let's code
this up
so back in the code we have the finite
state machine class
and this has a few public functions
there's the set state function
which first signals the old state that
it's exiting and sets the current state
and then notifies the new state that
it's active
there's also an update function that
gets called every frame and passes the
frame time and input to the currently
active state
now we'll make a character fsm class
which will just be a child
of the general finite state machine and
i just do that so i can add the
characters specific states here like
idle walk run and dance these add state
calls
what we're doing is passing the name of
the state and then the class that will
get instantiated to represent that state
so for instance when we switch to idle
the finite state machine will
instantiate an idle state
instance let's go over the states now
and we can see how they transition from
one state to the next
beginning with the idle state when we
enter the idle state
we want to set the character's animation
to idle so here in the enter function
this is responsible for playing the idle
animation
if there was a previous state like let's
say the character was walking before
all this code here does is tries to
cross fade them so the old one fades out
and the new one fades in
here's an example on the left is where
we do the crossfade so the character
kind of naturally comes to a halt
on the right there's no crossfade so it
kind of abruptly switches from one
animation to the next
you can see that one kind of looks jerky
and unnatural and the other looks pretty
smooth
next in the update function remember
from the diagram that it can transition
to
either a dance state if you press the
space or a walk state if you press
forward or backward
so in the update function here we'll
check the input if they're moving
forward or backward
we set the state to walk and if they
press the space bar
we set the state to dance next let's
look at the dance state
this is a pretty simple state the enter
function is doing two things
first it's playing the animation again
we crossfade like the idol did but we
also set some different parameters
specifically we only want to play this
once so we set
three dot loop once here and clamp when
finished to true
that just pauses the animation right at
the end once it's done
the other thing we do is set an event
listener to wait for the end of the
animation
because once the animation is done we
just set the state back to idle
the dance state doesn't do any updates
it just plays and then exits
moving on to the walk state this is
pretty similar to the idol in the enter
function we start playing the animation
trying to crossfade if there was another
animation before it
there's just one gotcha that i'll walk
through if the previous date was the
running state
we also want to smoothly fade in from
that but the legs might be in a totally
different place since the running
animation might be halfway through
so we don't want to just start the
walking animation
instead we skip ahead in the walking
animation a bit
the same percentage as the running
animation
that way when we start crossfading you
get a super smooth run to walk
let's watch without this on the left is
if we just crossfade which
kinda looks okay but not great depending
on where the legs were the model kind of
stumbles
if you catch it at the right moment it
looks great and seamless but at the
wrong moment
and it's stuttery now on the right we
have the animation synced and it always
looks smooth
doesn't matter which leg is going
forward or where they are in the cycle
we transition smoothly from walk to run
and vice versa
now the update function for the walk
state is pretty straightforward
you check if you're still walking
otherwise revert to idle
and if the shift key is being held down
switch to the run state
and i'll just skim run state quickly
because it's a near carbon copy of walk
state
the only difference here is in the
update function if they're not pressing
the shift key
revert to walk and that's it once you've
done all that
in the basic character controller class
if you add some velocity and direction
you've got a little walking character
it's not perfect but this should get you
started
you can see i can walk around a bit
looks pretty decent for the amount of
work and if i hold down the shift key
you can see breaks out into a little
trot
run around a bit and then once i let go
of the shift key he drops back and do a
walk
and if i let go it stops all together
finally
if i press the space bar he dances a
little jig
you could do so much more with this go
back to miximo and get a walk backwards
animation
or add some jumps attacks whatever suits
your purposes
hope you enjoyed this if you haven't
already subscribe both here and on
twitter
you'll get notifications when new videos
drop and previews on what's coming up
next
i also chat with people and try to get a
sense of what you all want to see next
make sure to like the video and leave a
comment about what you want to see
covered in a future tutorial
the code is all up on github so go ahead
grab it download it do whatever you want
with it
cheers everyone